HE IS WAKING UP FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY, HERE . AT PNC
ARENA.
>> TrippWAY BACK.
IN DOWN LOW, JUST  TO THE ORGAN
PLAYED IN SIENA GET  . AND IN T
SECONDS, ETHAN BEAR WILL COME
OUT OF THE PENALTY BOX.
THEY HAVE DONE  A BEAUTIFUL SHO
2-1
>> Tripp: TEUVO TERAVAINEN
ACROSS WITH PESCE
PLAY.
RIGHT HERE  YOU ARE COOKED.LOOK
TEUVO TERAVAINEN . IN OUT IN
FRONT IN EXCELLENT PLAY BY
D'ANGELO.  . THEN HE WILL UP WI
ON NICK LEDDY.
A LITTLE BIT OF HELP I
AND INTO THE RED WINGS IS OPENED
1:25 LEFT THIS IS EMOTIONAL FOR
E A
TON OF HOPE.
HE HAS
ROOM IN SETTING IT UP.
FOR ANDERSEN WITH THE BIG  SATH
THE THE COVID LIST.
THE FORMER ST. LOUIS BLUE IN
FIRST ROUND TREK.
TIP.
BUT IF YOU ARE A  COVID PROTOC
HERE IS A CHANCE.  NINO
NIEDERREITER THE HOCKEY PUCK IN
AT THE OFFENSIVE BLUE LINE.GAGN
>> Mike: THAT IS A STRONG LOOK
GET MARTIN NECAS .
IN A SKATE RAKE.
IT IS WON
>> Tripp: